-We are here with David Chase,
everybody,
the Emmy and Peabody-winning
writer and creator of
"The Sopranos," which premiered
25 years ago today
and is streaming on Max.
David, it is such a pleasure
to speak to you again.
I would imagine a lot of people
are asking you this.
25 years to the day
it premiered,
did you have any sense that you
were going to make a show
that people would still
be talking about
this much
a quarter century later?
-No, of course not. Not at all.
-Did you have any confidence
in it
at any point in the process?
-Well, yeah, five years in.
-Five years in?
-Yeah.
-But what about premiere day?
At the time, I feel,
you know, HBO was a thing.
We knew it was
prestige television.
I don't think we'd quite seen
anything like "The Sopranos."
Did HBO think they had
a hit on their hands?
-Well, I got a call --
It was going to happen
on January 10th,
and I got a call from a woman
whose name I wish
I could remember, who said,
"Listen, we have two kinds
of parties here on HBO.
There's a normal party
at series debuts,
cast, crew, and family,
a nice restaurant."
I said, "Oh, that sounds good."
And she said, "Then there's
another kind of party,
at a better restaurant,
at a big screening room,
a whole other thing."
And I thought, "Holy [bleep]."
And that's what happened.
-Wow.
So they upgraded you
to the big premiere.
-They upgraded me
-That's very exciting.
And the reviews early on,
everybody, almost to a
publication, loved it.
"Hollywood Reporter,"
"David Chase rises
to the challenge
with incredibly
absorbing scripts
and the help
of a remarkable cast."
"Newsday," "It's a great show.
The best new series of the year.
It's so,
dare I say it, original,
it catches you off guard."
"The Orlando Sentinel"
stands alone.
-Right. That's right.
-You remember this?
-I do remember this. Mm-hmm.
Of course I remember this.
-"A gangster's
midlife crisis is a weak,
unpalatable premise
for a series.
'The Sopranos' makes you
an offer you can refuse."
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
And one other journalist said
that they found that guy
in a barrel in Miami Bay.
[ Laughter ]
-You know,
I've watched this show
from beginning to end
multiple times now,
and it becomes so much,
through the series,
so much more fun
to watch everyone,
because you learn
who the characters are
and their peccadilloes
and the way they talk.
Did they become more fun to
write for, the longer it went?
Were there characters that you
were delighted to know,
you had a scene
with so and so?
-Oh, yeah, definitely.
-Did you have a favorite
person to write for?
-I guess I would say Junior.
-Yeah. Junior was great.
-Junior was just, I don't know.
-Well, first of all,
Olivia was everybody's,
every writer's favorite.
-Yes, Tony's mom.
-And then after she was gone,
it became Junior.
And I mean,
everybody was great,
but Junior had something
going for him,
and Paulie, you know?
-And the thing about it is the
show is obviously very serious.
People were very invested in
what happened to the characters,
the fates of everybody,
but it was so funny as well.
Did you feel you were
writing a drama?
writing a comedy,
or did it just switch based on
the scene and the character?
-Well, I remember being
at college up in the Bronx
and going to
somebody's funeral,
and on the way, I passed another
Italian funeral going on,
and there was these women
on their knees going,
[ Imitates sobbing ]
in front of the coffin.
"Oh, my God."
And I knew that
those were paid mourners.
And I thought, "This is
horrible and funny."
[ Laughter ]
So I thought,
"That's what I want to do."
-Yeah.
Well, you accomplished it.
Yet we talked about
how the confidence
came in Season Five.
You did not, even
with the critical praise,
you did not think it would
receive a second season?
-No, I didn't.
Because a show that survives
on TV,
it's a tiny, tiny bullseye
in the middle of a target,
you know?
Edie Falco said to me --
and also, we were done with
the whole show before it aired.
That's not the way it usually
works on network TV.
You're working on it
while it's on the air.
So Edie said to me,
"So what happens now?"
And I said, "Well, not much.
I think we've done it
and we had a really good time,
and it was great."
And she said, "Why?"
I said, "It's just not
going to happen.
It doesn't ever happen, really."
And she said,
"Well, we had so much fun."
I said, "No,
they don't want you to have fun.
That's not the purpose.
That's the problem."
-You would make
a terrible cheerleader.
-I tried out in high school.
-You tried out in high school?
-They said, "You know, we got
a job on the paid mourner team."
-That's right.
But they didn't pay enough.
-They didn't pay enough.
But you also, it's interesting
because, you know, again,
I think a lot of the people
in the show had worked before.
It's what they became known for.
You did have a career
in television,
so you'd been
through this before.
You'd worked on shows
that succeeded,
like "The Rockford Files,"
"Northern Exposure."
But you also had some ideas
before "The Sopranos"
of shows that did not succeed,
including
a Superman-inspired show.
-Yes. That's true.
-What was the name
of your Superman show?
-The Superman-inspired show
was called "Ultimo."
-"Ultimo."
-And it was about
an Italian-American kid
whose father was
a scientist
at the Houston Space Lab,
and his father took him
to work on a Saturday,
and the kid ate
some little moon rocks,
and it never came out
in his stool.
And he got these superpowers,
and then
he had to start hiring
publicity people,
legal people, had a whole
Tuesday morning staff meeting,
because in the pilot,
he was being sued
because he took a big boulder
off a mountain
and smashed
some terrorists in a cabin.
And that caused vibration,
which caused a ski lift
to fall down,
and a lot of people
were seriously injured.
So he was being sued
by all those people.
-And how did the network
receive this script?
-The way they received
all of them.
[ Laughter ]
-You did not,
going into "The Sopranos,"
you preferred film
as a medium to television.
And I think you started, or it
was certainly one of the shows
that started this shift to a far
more cinematic television.
Was that one of the things
you set out to do?
-Yes. It was, yeah.
-And was HBO amenable to this?
Was that something you had
to explain to them?
-No, I did not.
I've said it before,
HBO was like --
I was all set to do
another development deal at Fox
and to be at the executive
producer of "Millennium."
Do you remember that show?
-Yeah, I remember that show.
And I went
to a meeting over there,
and then I had another meeting
around the corner at HBO,
and I said to HBO,
"Well, can I direct a pilot?
Because if I can,
then I'll do it."
And they said yes,
so that other one,
which was a contract signing
meeting, never happened.
-Wow, that's amazing
how a very small --
Always have two meetings
in the same day.
That's the real...
-Yeah.
-We've had cast members,
I've read interviews.
I had cast members here
who've talked about
how actual members of the mob
had reached out to them
during the filming of the show,
after the filming of the show,
because they wanted to,
you know, just talk to people
who were on "The Sopranos."
I think that was probably a show
that was interesting to them.
Did members of the actual
Mafia ever try to contact you?
-No. Although,
I have to be careful here.
-Yeah, I have to be.
Make sure it's only a one-shot.
-Yeah, yeah, I have...
I think he's gone now.
I had a cousin by marriage
who was married to an older
cousin of mine, a woman.
And I never went there,
for obvious reasons,
And right toward the end,
maybe fifth or sixth season,
my wife and I
had dinner with those two,
and we had a night
in Clifton, New Jersey,
two minutes from
where I grew up,
and we had a nice dinner.
And, he and I said,
"You know what?
Let's forget all this [bleep].
Let's you and I have lunch."
We made a lunch date for
two Thursdays from now,
and starting on Wednesday.
I started thinking,
"I don't know about this.
I don't know about this.
I don't think
this is a good idea."
And by Thursday,
I was pretty much agitated,
and I almost had my hand on
the phone, and the phone rings.
I answer the phone. It's him.
He says,
"David, I've been thinking,
I don't think we should
do this."
So that was, you know --
-Probably for the best.
-That was definitely
for the best,
because he had already asked me
for Springsteen tickets.
-Yeah.
-And, you know.
-Yeah, you don't need people --
If he's really in the Mafia,
he can get his own
Springsteen tickets.
-Well, you would think so.
I mean, it was that
and some other stuff.
It had already started.
-Yeah.
-It's hard enough
having a cousin by marriage.
You don't need them
also in the mob.
-Right,
but that cousin is the guy
that told me and Terry Winter
about a guy from Newark
who shot his wife
in the beehive hairdo.
-Oh, really?
-That's where that came from,
from that cousin.
-See, that's why
he couldn't keep talking to you.
They would eventually be like,
"Hey, these are
a lot of your stories."
HBO put together
a quick clip package
of "The Sopranos"
on its 25th anniversary.
Let's take a look.
-I'd like to propose
a toast to my family.
Someday soon, you're gonna
have families of your own,
and if you're lucky,
you'll remember
the little moments
that were good.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is it strange to watch
a clip package?
-Uh...
Seems very violent to me.
-It's a very violent show.
If you haven't seen it,
it's a very violent show.
What an honor to have you here.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-David Chase.
"The Sopranos" streaming on Max.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."